forty finals 20 winners $100,000 to drop
out of school and pursue our dreams this
is team technorati after a long weekend
of lightning pitches in mentor matches
it's time for us finalists to leave San
Francisco and head back to reality I
think that you'll take away from this
not only the feeling that you're not
alone but you have people that you can
reach out to and that will help you
achieve your world-changing goals we've
done all we can do and now it's up to
the judges to determine who will be
receiving the 20 TL Foundation grants
the Team Foundation likes to give grants
to people who are trying to advance the
frontiers of knowledge I'm worried the
FDA will kill Catherine's creativity
Catherine's idea for developing modular
components to make powered wheelchairs
more useful even if that idea doesn't
work out she's gonna have a whole series
of really impressive things over the
course of her life Darby I think she has
what it takes to get it done just has a
lot of work ahead of her I was excited
about the space I thought it was neat
but I just wanted to see more oh are you
proposed a very technical project but
she's a non-technical finalist I wanted
to feel like it was more than just an
idea she's pitching us but something
that she was really building because
it's too important to wait on do they
have the technical chops that's needed
to move forward
socially do we think that the group
would be cohesive two years is a long
time and we all want to feel good about
you know who were around for that time
period
actually Thomas hunt he's trying to
solve a really difficult problem he cuts
to the chase I'm trying to cure cancer
he's actually in labs doing real science
learning because she thinks it's
important rather than because
institutions say that you need to do
these things
David Meese I love that he's compiled
all this data on socio-political
conflicts and has developed a predictive
algorithm that the government purchased
because it actually worth David actually
wants to make the world a better place
everyone seemed to love him whether
finalists our community I like him a lot
but I'm just trying to keep my bias in
check I think they're the technology to
a degree is there or one expert in
supercomputing thinks the processing
that he suggests he can bring about just
as impossible on these devices
how will he respond to that brick wall
when he hits it
going back to like normal life is always
a trip I guess Andrew I think the doc
bought product is probably a little
before its time something like this will
happen it's an open question whether
Andrews product is the one let's talk
about Luci the educational game space is
very competitive
Lucy's really strong because she
iterates fast we've seen her at many
hackathons each time it's a new idea she
hacked into her dad's computer to find
its password so she could still play
games she certainly has a lot of talent
I really want to talk about Ryan
he's infectious maybe a little too
infectious for some but he's built a
product that has some traction he's a
great designer some people thought he
was a little too self-promotional and
self-interested
be curious to see what other ideas he
has it's less about flipping a company
on the short term and more about
thinking about ideas across a longer
period in time I think we have to debate
Ryan further any time I can learn
something and improve and take away a
message or a lesson it's great and I
felt like this weekend was just lesson
after lesson message after message
I saw the only thing I would give up
college for would be to be a teal fellow
because it's such an incredible
opportunity but like I love my college
so much I love USC I understand you
don't need a college degree to change
the world but a college degree doesn't
mean a lot I just had a distorted
perception coming into this weekend and
it's kind of cleared a lot of things up
you just had that winning mentality and
like I'm gonna try and learn absorb kind
of a sponge take everything in I think
it was a humbling experience for him
since he wasn't the technical guy on the
team I think if he divided it himself
over the next couple years to this that
he could really start making his own
discoveries in the field the hundred
thousand dollars to be honest doesn't
factor in to my equation because I'd
also be leaving theoretically $150,000
on the table if I left USC and gave up
my scholarship there
next time the judges decide which of us
get $100,000 Graham and we decide if
we'll take them so be sure to subscribe
to the wire channel for the final
installment of a teen technorati